today's topic it's not because you feel
something it's not because you feel
something oh no no no the [ __ ] down
some people think just because they feel
something it means that they're entitled
to express that emotion you feel jealous
[ __ ] keep it to yourself nobody needs
to know it's not real until you do
something jealous it's not real until
you see it if you can observe it it's
not you do you understand what I'm
saying if you can observe yourself being
depressed doesn't mean that depression
is you it is a state that you're going
through it's like driving under an
underpass it's dark in there we
understand it but it's not you you just
are in the darkness that darkness is not
you and I know this sounds very
philosophical but I mean for me it's
important for people to understand that
because that separation itself with what
you're feeling is super important you
can let it pass you don't have to feed
it you don't have to believe it's you
once you understand there's that
separation whatever you're feeling
it's just transient it will pass it's
not crazy for you to feel angry I've got
angry all the time
maybe you make me mad all the time I'm a
nice person yeah make me mad all the
time but you know what as long as I
don't act on it it's not real yeah cuz
you're getting mad with some [ __ ] [ __ ]
hmm what's it I said you get mad over
some little [ __ ] [ __ ] it's not real
[ __ ] is [ __ ] [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up what
you'll see she's being a little [ __ ]
see that feeling you're feeling right
now I'm gonna pass
[Music]
things like you meet when you know that
you're not going what if you can't
observe it it's not you
and that's empowering that helped me get
through my depression Real Talk really
anything I can see is not my eyes right
you can't see your eyes right you're
seeing me I mean that you see your
reflection oh right and so if you can
observe it just understand the strength
that it sounds so minor but it's
actually super powerful and it just made
me realize how a lot of emotions are
like whatever who cares and you realize
after a lot of great things happen to us
we never get to happy we get happy but
it passes because we can observe it
because it is not us it is what we do
boy movement I get that right hey relax
I feel good a pass a real talk and we
also never get too sad on ourselves when
things fail we've had some opportunities
this year not go through and none of us
got bummed out because we have that even
playing field we can observe that
feelings here to do wrong
there's plenty people who are in our
position who have other [ __ ] to do who
when something doesn't go well they
break down true but I'm not damn cuz I
can observe them
oh boy move it there see you do it
yeah you know who helped me overcome my
depression just reflux of wars going on
the world with what happened you have to
know that like I was a reason where that
I was where I was so I had to kick my
[ __ ] up if I was just saying there in
that state
I was just become what I was observing
you know what I mean so it's like when
you're drifting
now you don't try it but when you drift
you will go when you're and I'm a
motorcycle you will go where you look
just like when you're unbias with
friends on a bike you're on the bike
you're looking at your friend and all of
a sudden your bike go like this yeah
because where you're looking at you tend
to go towards so if I was I just feel
like that if I was just looking at the
bottom always and always fixating on the
on the on the negative and what I was
doing wrong wrong wrong I was just I
kept on going there you know I mean
where I was like okay what can I do to
make myself better and get the [ __ ] out
of this [ __ ] all right and then you
fixate or something else says yourself a
goal I was just focused on that I'm to
focus on that even though most of the
time I'm not focused so I would just
caution people to really start to get
within their own heads and understand
what it what your sense of self is what
it means you know what it means to be
secure what it means to actually have
confidence what does that really mean
you know I think when people said
something about like oh you know needing
attention it's okay it's fine you know
that we all need that to instill a sense
of confidence it doesn't matter if a
thousand men compliment you it doesn't
matter for a hundred thousand men
complements you that's not a real sense
of security why because if those hundred
thousands of men stop complimenting you
you don't have security your foundation
is built on sand right it has to be
inwardly built it cannot be external if
you need that kind of validation from
the outside it's not sustainable your
beauty is gonna faint your looks are
gonna fade the attention you're gonna
receive from the community is gonna fail
you have to find something else to
really build on this is not you know
some attempt to shame people who feel
such as insecurity I felt those that
same way but for me I've learned to
build my foundation on something far
more
poor it's why I look dusty in all these
videos you know I'm saying because
because for me my sense of you know
confidence has been really well
instilled so that when I got into this
comedy game and I said you know I'm
gonna do this YouTube player is gonna go
big I'm gonna do this comedy thing it's
gonna be my career path people like
that's crazy you're doing something
stupid I have such a sense of
understanding itself I didn't need the
outside world to be like you can do it I
was like [ __ ] y'all I'll do it I'm gonna
do it and it had to come from the inside
and so for everybody watching is not
nice you don't have to look externally
like start asking yourself questions
have these conversations with yourself
so these are some of the tips that we
have in terms of dealing with some of
the emotional stress that you guys are
having again emotions are fleeting it's
okay so be smart chill breathe if you're
fighting with somebody chill breathe
it's gonna be okay
brain to stop real look you gotta
breathe it stop for real what yeah hey
all my people peace officers Jenner news
[Music]